they've lost control and
you know it makes me feel real good it's
great it's beautiful to see joe we're
going to have jordan peterson on and oh
boy are they all triggered well culti
leftists are like oh no and they're
lying it's so it's so hilarious how like
dude when you take a clip from joe's
show
and then post it along with a quote that
joe did not say
you're a [ __ ] people anyone can watch
it right but and so when the people are
sharing it i see this clip where it's
like joe rogan said unless someone is
100 black you can't call him black and i
was like i'm going to watch this clip
and joe said nothing of the sort
nothing of the sort of just making
things up yeah i mean he
some of those things were like
tangentially related what he was talking
about he said it was basically strange
that there's like people from all over
the world of different skin tones and
different backgrounds and like just
calling all of them black just kind of
seems kind of weird because they're
different people from different you know
and i was like yeah you know like
sure i get what joe's trying to say but
then to take that claim
that joe's saying unless someone's 100
black you can't call them black i was
like why would they just lie about that
so when someone then retweets that i'm
just like these are not serious people
no you you it's good though because you
know they're just lying yeah i don't
think a single person believes when they
retweet them like that and they're like
oh look at what joe said i'm like i know
you don't believe that yeah cause like
you can listen to the guy and what joe
rogan is saying actually opens up a very
interesting discussion which is the fact
that in the united states of america
black people have a racial identity but
not an ethnic identity because of the
tragic history there and the fact that
they don't know which part of africa
they're from is individual people
whereas with the white population a
person generally knows if they're irish
german english dutch whatever ancestry
they have and there's some something
tragic there and it shapes the way that
a culture operates but of course the
media has to turn that into
joe rogan is racist and says you can't
call someone black unless they're 100
black it's ridiculous
well you know from the outside it looks
crazy the the self you know the identity
issues uh and and it sounds to me like
rogan was highlighting that it's like
well how do you calculate
who's one color versus the other
especially since we now
envision people being able to
self-identify any way they want yeah and
you know uh
the left enjoys that they like that but
the downside of that is it's going to
blow up
the anti-discrimination infrastructure
we have here in the united states
so if you have laws that protect uh uh
women from being discriminated against
or you have laws that protect people
from being discriminated on the basis of
race if they self-identify in ways that
you know are kind of raise issues in
that regard well how are the laws
applied
and so there's this kind of war
on reality in some respects but also war
on the law in terms of discrimination
they they don't believe in these
anti-discrimination laws
because the way they talk and think
about them would would actually negate
them and make them inapplicable yeah i
think for me one thing that uh
you know instantly broke me out of the
left lies i just immediately saw it was
how you know someone can identify as
whatever they want
as long as you agree with their
political ideology yeah like someone
super chatted us this the other day they
said
black people can't be racist but candace
owens is racist yes exactly okay hold on
there a minute because according to
their that makes no sense yeah but they
say it well for a marxist it makes
perfect sense yeah i mean that's why you
oppose it i mean that's communism 101
she has false consciousness and she's
not black well i mean that's that's
communism well it's interesting because
the question i've always wanted to ask
they always pose this as a question of
black verse swipe and it's like okay
well like what if a black person hates
an asian person or what if an asian
person hates a black person or a
hispanic person hates a black person
like if you're not white you can't be
racist so is that not racist what if an
asian person is black
the oh yeah i'm about to bend some minds
yo yeah people can't believe what if
what if everyone in this room hates an
irishman well you guys all do based on
the way i'm treated now to be fair
and i know and i've said this on the
show before i know people who are like
actually born and raised in ireland get
upset when you say you're irish and
you've only lived in america but here's
the thing it's not like i'm not bragging
it's an admission all right it's just
like okay yes this is confession where
my ancestors
but i'm pretty sure everyone in this
room is no everyone's got some irish are
you irish yes that's because the hand
that rocks the cradle rules the world
baby
all right
but but the other thing too is uh
i find it hilarious when i see people
talking about me on you know like reddit
or something and they're they say like
people
like i don't know why people will be
like tim pool doesn't identify as white
or whatever and i'm just like i have no
idea what that means no dude i don't
identify as white what does that mean i
don't know what that means yeah it's
supposed to be your skin color but it's
not no one's white no one has white skin
it's crazy but look
wait either the left social justice
marxist cult or whatever doesn't view
race as skin color they view race as
political
then yeah later
depending on like the man this is what
they do
in order to win an argument they'll use
they have two different paths they can
take with the same language
so they can say no i'm not talking about
politics i'm talking about how someone
can look at this men discriminate
against them and then later they'll be
like i'm not talking about skin calm
talking about the politics of blackness
the political black like okay dude
you're talking about whatever gets you
power exactly
well and this is the thing i mean
when they talk about being white or
identifying as white
they fail to take into account how an
individual person actually identifies
themselves and so i understand their
argument that because i'm white i don't
really think about my skin color etc but
if you look culturally at my you know
upbringing being from an irish catholic
home in the chicago area and you compare
that to the upbringing of a white dutch
person or a white english person who was
raised in a protestant home or without
religion you'd actually find and i have
found this
just based on the churches i've been to
throughout my life is that i have far
more in common with a person on the
basis of what religion they were raised
in as as opposed to their skin color and
so when you're you're talking to a black
person or a mexican person who was
raised in a catholic household you can
just relate on a level that i don't
relate to on somebody just because just
because they're white it's ridiculous
that's not how i identify i have more
common with people that like play blue
and magic the gathering than their their
skin color i don't care about uh it was
uh matt walsh made this point about uh
when he's on dr phil he said we can dig
up a skeleton hundreds of years later we
can't know what they were thinking but
we can know it's you know male or female
or whatever and i think that that
actually says a lot more than just that
conversation it's it's like you are so
much more
as to who you are on the inside your
values the things you believe than what
you look like you know what i mean and
it's such a funny thing i joke about
this but like in the united states irish
people were not like considered white
until being white meant you had to
apologize for being white
well there you go yeah congratulations
no i know but no it's just interesting
because like whiteness is a label that
was actually used to bludgeon my
ancestors so when you look at who was
excluded from the united states
and the people who had a light skin tone
who were considered non-white it was
almost always catholic groups
and what's frustrating to me is that
we're having this conversation and you
know it's one thing to have the
conversation it's another thing to be in
positions where you're in a school and
you're a teacher
or you're in government and you're being
told
you are a bad person because of the
color of your skin
so the crt or whatever you want to call
it this uh the uh
the woke uh approach it's not just about
it's offensive morally and
intellectually yeah as applied it's
illegal
okay you're not supposed to discriminate
on the basis of race and select people
on the basis of race i mean we we just
had settled a lawsuit
in asheville north carolina they had a
scholarship program
only black kids could apply
completely outrageous yeah that's insane
so we filed a civil rights claim against
them and they settled and they changed
the rules so that it's you know i don't
know it's race neutral well so let me
let me ask you but it's it but they're
trying to undo
constitutional protections of equal
protection of the law and the civil
rights laws of the sixties they're
trying to do it we're trying to defend
it and i don't mean us judicial watch we
are literally but i mean us who are
conservatives and follow the rule of law
we actually believe in
non-discrimination they don't isn't that
crazy how they flip the script on you
guys we're civil we're the civil rights
advocates the craziest thing to me was
this past election when we had
california trying to repeal the civil
rights language from their constitution
did you see that one
it was it was they called it the
affirmative action amendment it was such
a sleazy title for a bill it literally
would just strip out from the california
constitution the language says you
cannot discriminate on the basis of race
you know sex uh sexuality or origin or
whatever in public accommodation or
knows in public employment contracting
and schooling or something like that and
they were like we need to get rid of
this so that we can be fair and treat
minorities fair and i'm like when we
we fought for civil rights in this
country to make sure the law would not
take these factors into into account and
now the left is trying to repeal that
language in california they lost by the
way
but i remember you know i've told you
guys the story before but those who
haven't heard it i was talking to a
friend of mine an activist a prominent
you know well-known celebrity in in in
hollywood and we're having a
conversation because we've been drifting
apart politically and i said
what's the what's the what's the you
know the racial makeup of california and
it's like 70 was it 70 white or
something like that and i said
so if do you think that when california
repeals their non-discrimination
language from the constitution that the
70 white majority is going to protect
the minorities now or do you think
they'll just either consciously or
unconsciously start benefiting
themselves in their race
and and there's there's no real answer i
get from these people
because they don't want to admit they're
wrong in repealing this language because
it's part of their tribe but i was like
look some of these cities in california
are like 99 white
and if your perspective is that white
people are racist why would you empower
these people to discriminate on the
basis of race and they have no answer
they have none now i got to be honest i
don't really think white people in
california are going to be like ah now's
our chance to be racist yeah
but if that's their ideology why would
they want to repeal that language unless
they actually want to be racist and they
actually want to do these things yeah
exactly well because these white people
aren't going to be like i can like
oppress other people who are non-white
but they could go i'm gonna make myself
feel better about this white guilt
complex by a pr like discriminating
against white people i don't i gotta be
honest
i i really think that what we're dealing
with in the culture war stems largely
from those in the know and those who
aren't that's really it i mean if you if
you go to i went to the march for our
march for our lives i think it was that
was the gun thing
and i saw all these people holding up
signs saying ban assault weapons or
whatever right and i'd ask them like you
know what does that mean yeah and they
they couldn't tell me and i there are
several people that said you know uh
assault rifles should be illegal or
should be you know like ban assault
rifles and so i'd stop and i talked to
people and i'd be like i wanted to ask
you about your son and i said uh so you
want to ban assault rifles and they'd be
like yeah and i'd be like
well they're almost entirely banned you
can't make any new ones i think since
1984. and in order to get one now it
requires you know a special licensing to
take take up to a year the tax yeah the
tax they're typically very expensive
they can be thousands of dollars and
they would go oh i didn't know that i'm
like what are you protesting i wasn't
mean any i was just like okay i had one
woman
she was holding up a sign and i asked
her these questions and then she folded
it up and you're like oh i didn't know
i'm like then what are you protesting
so i i genuinely believe a lot of these
people just don't know so
this activist friend of mine
posted something recently from the march
for life you know sheamus you were down
there yes and it was some like lefty guy
walking up to protesters and saying how
many children have you adopted and it
was like this bumbling middle-aged woman
she goes none and he goes oh okay i've
adopted two and she goes great and then
he goes another how many of you adopted
and she's like i've not adopted any kids
and he's like i've adopted two it's like
okay and i'm watching this and i'm like
what message
is my friend trying to convey with this
that these two women haven't adopted any
children most people don't adopt
children is this an indictment of the
pro-life movement yeah they just don't
know if they went down there and they
spoke to any of the organizers they'd be
like oh
look a lot of the organizers a lot of
people involved do run charities for
helping children and promoting adoption
and they do adopt a whole lot but they
just don't know anything about this
why
well i think
apathy
a lot of people just don't care they
want to pretend to care it makes them
look good on social media right yep
general ignorance it's not their jobs to
be journalists you know i don't blame
every single person for just not knowing
some people look you work your nine to
five you go home you got you want to be
with your kids you want to play maybe
throw throw a football a little bit you
don't got time to sit down and read all
this stuff yeah and but but i will blame
the uh mainstream press to a great
degree thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you